what's up guys bang bang it is lunch
money time on a friday you know what
that means there's some trillionaire
energy in the air
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
plena evil marinova
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto you can deposit crypto and earn
up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account
interest bearing account
interest bearing account it's not a
crypto constant interest banner crypto
exchange
we already talked about that one and the
third product is that you can deposit
crypto take out a us dollar alone
against your crypto collateral go get a
block five account if you have a block
five account today you can get on the
wait list for a credit card that pays
you in bitcoin rewards
go and sign up at block five dot com
slash pomp block fight.com
pomp you can go to blockclock.com
what's up i'm still i'm still really
white i need a tan
okay former trump
economic adviser kevin hassett broadly
supports
joe biden's 1.9 trillion dollar rescue
package
as a way to keep the coronav virus
ravaged economy
afloat so he said they've thrown a lot
of stimulus at it
but i think we need to be risk-averse i
don't know what that means
listen oh my voice is cracked was that a
crack
that was a crack did my voice just crack
that was a crap it's better than a yawn
all right so listen if they want to
print and create another 1.9 trillion
dollars in a stimulus package they're
going to do it regardless of what we all
think they literally do not care what we
think
but three things are gonna happen one
they're gonna punish savers
two they're gonna inflate asset prices
and three is they are going to run a
marketing campaign
as to why the digital decentralized
financial system
is a better alternative because people
cannot change
the rules in the new system without most
people agreeing she just yawned that is
what you get when you sleep i slept 10
hours last night what's up
trillionaire energy but for the stimulus
package
at some point we got to knock it off
they're not going to
but let's go open the economy let people
run their businesses
and you want to print all this money but
again the financial incentive is
politicians are going to do it they're
going to try to mitigate short-term pain
and they are going to devalue the dollar
and they're going to be handing out cash
cash cash joe biden's going to be in the
streets just throwing it
like he's at a strip club and he's just
going to be handing it to everybody
and what he means when he says open the
economy i've seen the comments he means
do it safely wear the masks if you're
old if you're at risk
stay home do your job from there if you
can
are people mad that i've been saying
that well it's like yes if you open the
economy then the virus will shoot back
up
that's not necessarily true well if you
if you actually look at the places where
the economy is open it doesn't
necessarily have the worst
uh situation but i think it does it
doesn't
uh but what i will say again is if
you're old if you're sick
or if you're scared even if you don't
have any actual issues but you're just
nervous
you should sit at home that's fine like
that shouldn't be a problem the whole
thing though is for those that are young
let them go let them go safely with
masks
true and social distancing go ahead next
um
janet yellen is clarifying some of her
comments
around crypto she thinks it's important
that the us considers the benefits of
cryptocurrency
alongside the potential for misuse she
said i think we need to look
closely at how to encourage their use of
legitimate activities
while curtailing their use for maligned
and illegal
activities if confirmed i intend to work
closely with the federal reserve board
and the other federal banking and
securities regulators on how to
implement an effective regulatory
framework for those in other fintech
innovators where are you pointing out
because i thought that went off the yawn
was coming
so what do we think uh i think that
janet yellen thank you janet i
appreciate you for clarifying your
thoughts
i think that this is a much more nuanced
and more appropriate answer
that we should look at the positives
along with the negatives
i really hope that you are listening to
all the feedback on the internet
because that will embolden people to
continue to share that feedback
but the us dollar still choice currency
of all criminals around the world
all right so i have a very interesting
this is a very interesting article
bank of america is giving dollars in
cash bonuses
to staffers in the us who earn less than
100k
but for employ employees who make
between 100k and 500k annually
they'll get 150 to 750 restricted
stock units so one group is getting cash
the other group is getting stock
well i'll even go a step further
and then it's over four years oh it's
over four years
the vesting the stock awards will be
paid out over four years
listen i like the fact that companies
want to pay
employees more i like the fact that they
want to even give some upside and equity
but you're telling me 750 dollar bonus
sure maybe it has a little bit of an
impact but if you're making 90
000 or 100 yeah up to 100 000. if you're
making 90 000
a year you get a 750 bonus
is that really that meaningful but i
just don't why is one group getting
stock and the other one is cash that's
another question
my guess is that there might be
something around
uh the positions that they hold
but what ends up occurring here
it sounds like somebody's getting
screwed
maybe we should not be making decisions
on based on income and maybe we should
be making decisions based on something
else
but i but i want to be very clear
everyone will always critique
how they do something like this but you
have to give kudos that they're doing it
at all that's true so it's a positive
that they're doing it but then people
will all debate
the nuances i'm not asking i'm saying
it's a good thing but
why is there why isn't everybody getting
stock options
well i don't know but bank of america
has been giving employees a thousand
dollars since 2017 as bonuses
but they stopped it i believe during the
pandemic so they're bringing it back
but it's actually lower than it was
pre-pandemic
well because everyone's worried about
cash yeah so give them the cash
no the company is worried about the cash
um wait but i have a question
is it better to get 750
in cash or 750 in stock
units over investing over four years
well it depends
if the stock goes up or goes down right
right
the other thing that's very interesting
is bank of america i believe was the
first or one of the early banks they
moved to a minimum wage of 20
at bank of america and they i think they
did that last year the year before
um and so again they're trying to do the
right things
and i think that like their hearts in
the right place when you look at some of
the
uh programs they're putting in place
it's just of course people are gonna
always debate
you know what's the right decision
what's not whatever
tesla chief and billionaire entrepreneur
elon musk
on thursday took to twitter to promise a
hundred million dollar prize
for development of the best technology
to capture
carbon dioxide emissions
i literally saw people on twitter
complaining about this i literally saw
journalists being like
oh my god i can't believe that everyone
is saying such positive things about
this we don't even know the details yet
like like what
the man literally said he's gonna give
a hundred million dollars
to somebody who comes up with innovation
but the critics might say
he's just doing it for positive press he
cares
he's not serious about it he tweeted it
yeah but he might not do it what do you
mean
just because you tweeted doesn't mean
you'll do it
okay so guess what if he doesn't do it
later
then right ahead should i tweet i'm
gonna give a hundred million dollars so
somebody reads my uh
horoscope yes and and then when you
don't do it i'm gonna write a hit piece
and be like you didn't do it
it's like we live in this world where
literally everyone wants to critique
everything before it even happens
it's like somebody comes out and they're
like i'm going to start a business and
then somebody's like oh my god but if
the business doesn't work what a bad
person
wait for the business to fail that's
literally how i used to think
and he was like you should do it and
then figure it out
yeah what like it's just everyone
loves to be a critic but i don't
see i don't see anyone that's writing
those pieces
giving away any money i don't see any of
them
so when they start to give away their
money all right they then can critique
other people who are giving away money
they can do what
critique okay why did i say it wrong oh
all right
i'm being a negative nancy his um
his neck is a little bit my next i i've
been working for y'all
all week if people knew yesterday i sat
in the same chair from 7 30 until seven
o'clock at night and i had to hear
everything i recorded like six podcasts
i did a bunch of meetings all that stuff
like a little hermit crab over the
computer
go ahead okay um japan says
it is committed to host the olympics and
it's denying reports
of a cancellation it is committed to
open
have the opening ceremony for the games
on july 23rd
after having been postponed in march
last year
i mean i hope the olympics happened but
like is there gonna be an audience like
it's gonna be the saddest olympics ever
oh we got four minutes uh listen my
whole thing sorry i gotta do a call
i just i realized the olympics i can do
it myself
i could do lunch money by myself
the olympics is uh a great time i love
the olympics america will win all the
gold medals sorry for everybody else
uh but just uh win sorry sorry we're the
fastest strongest coolest
uh sleekest swimmers in the world it's
not just one
i know that right okay all right next
all right it's lunch money time
lunch money time ask ellen in the
comments
below what you got for us oh daniel's
back daniel bella front
now bella fonte bella front pimp
oh that's for me about media trust
coming from a journalism background what
do you believe the roadmap
roadmap back to cold hard facts and away
from being
first or spouting opinions could and
should
look like so there's this thing called
the spj code of ethics that i think if
more media organizations abided by we
wouldn't have the problems that we have
but somehow that's kind of like fallen
to the wayside and now we're all
bloggers and
every we're offering our opinions left
and right
i actually think it's gonna have to i
genuinely believe that the media acts as
a mirror to society
i think when people are tired of all the
extremist nonsense
then we're gonna start moving back
towards the middle
and i think the our media will reflect
that because
it won't just be like oh they only want
to read about trump
trump trump trump trump like it'll be a
little bit more
calm and moderate and independent and
ethical
but i think it needs to come from
society first
i don't think it's possible he doesn't
think
you can't you can't have
a corrupt or a non-corrupt unbiased
organization when the people that the
organization is made up of
are corrupted by right but my point is
if our consumption habits as a society
change those organizations will be
forced to change the types of people
they hire they started hiring the
bloggers because
buzzfeed was killing it
yes it's okay we can agree to this the
future
of cold hard facts is not in
organizations
it's in individuals you're going to find
the one individual that you trust
that you believe that you say hey i
agree with their read the profile.com
library the profile.com and that's who
you're going to end up listening to
you're not going to you're not going to
subscribe to the institutional brand
you're going to subscribe to the
individual brand
guys i saw you yesterday making fun of
my big water bottle so today i got a
mini one
okay i'm very versatile i normally have
my own water bottle but
it's a long story okay brent katie
in each of your opinions what is a
worthwhile skill to learn for the future
something relatively difficult that may
take some time to educate yourself but
would pay
dividends down the road um
investing personal finance
easy that's it investing in personal
finance
you'll always be able to have a living
you'll always be secure if you know how
to take capital
and grow it see you guys on monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends